the Joe Rogan experience one of the
reasons I was really excited about you
being today is because this weekend
there's there's a it's a great fight
card like the steep ADCC rematches an
amazing car amazing fight for that card
I love the card in general but the Paulo
Costa Yoel Romero fight that's the one
that perplexes me like how does that go
down what happens when these tool
[ __ ] Brahma Bulls smash heads in the
middle of the Octagon first of all it's
all-time best body fight ever right yes
oh for sure absolutely how do you they
both like the chairs without rockets
they look like statues of gods both of
them if you grant through options for
bodies if you could choose like its flip
a coin these guys get robbed
either way whether Costa Romero might
have an advantage because he's so
freakish he's so freakishly built that I
mean you can't imagine someone having a
better body yeah you just have a
different body it's just it's either two
of them there look at yeah well look at
y'all and right there when he's posing
he doesn't even look what Jesus Christ
he's such a tank the thing the
difference in the in this in this fight
between the two is that I think well we
know Romero can fight for five rounds
and he will take his time early but
Costa comes out throwing guns strange
dangerous man wild coast is very very
very dangerous he's got outstanding
striking he's got real power and he's
fast he's fast and powerful the thing is
though is he as fast and powerful as you
well and you know he's beating really
good guys like Uriah Hall but this is
the cream of the crop I mean he's in
there against the [ __ ] of all
[ __ ] at 185 you talk about a
dude who just can explode on you and
send you flying through the air
yeah he ragdolls people he does people
to shoot to people when he's wrestling
them and you just go what the [ __ ] he
jumps at them with shots when he knocked
out Luke Rockhold with that left hand
you like what the [ __ ] not shotgun too
many steps in boom and then kisses him
get the [ __ ] out of your manners he's as
David Goggin say stole souls yeah he
stole souls is a ridiculous athlete
I'm predict my cell is that Paulo Kostas
undefeated mentality might play into
play into Romero's hands a bit because
cost is gonna come crashing forward and
Romero will just take his time maybe and
Costa has gassed I mean the guest on The
Ultimate Fighter so if he fights hard
for a couple of rounds and Romero's you
know still strong in the third I think
he's a different guy now I really do
yeah I mean I think I think Paul Costa
is at the top of the heap for a real
reason now and a lot of it is dedication
well lead Ishmael like I was a lunatic I
love that guy he's training he's awesome
yeah and right days Paolo Costa is
working with them and talked to me about
him and you know how crazy Willy is he's
like he measures his food that's it he
kept saying he measures his food like
that dude has like everything portioned
out he's just like a hundred percent
eyes on the prize he goes that's all he
does his trained he goes this guy
doesn't party doesn't [ __ ] around he's
just concentrating on measuring his food
and training so what about the money
that Romero has come into recently crazy
changes mentality oh here's the thing
man I don't know if it's real I don't
know if they're ever gonna give him that
money really to stare down that's the
guy not to tangle do security Steve Reed
on the right side Steve's a bad
[ __ ] he's got eyes yeah the
dudes eyes like yeah [ __ ] up he saved
a couple of shows in Europe that could
have gone very good agon south oh I'm
sure I have a little story for you from
the Gdansk show so I'm standing on stage
at the weigh-ins I'm announcing the
fights as they come out and we have a
fight on the card we have a Polish
fighter against Anthony Hamilton and I
had the voice come through in my ear
saying that that fight wasn't gonna be
walking so just to drop it off the
schedule like during the weigh-ins are
going and immediately I'm thinking
that's kind of kind of strange and I'm
not sure whether obviously you know some
areas of Poland there's a racial
undertone I wasn't sure whether it was
because Anthony Hamilton was gonna get
some heat if he walks out on stage the
next thing I've got quite a unique
perspective because I can see down the
two tunnels where the fans walk into the
floor and I saw this whole bunch of like
skinheads with black bomber jackets and
boots just come marching in and they
filled the floor space and then they
went oh and Saturday
one of the blocks and just sat there
waiting for him and it was because he
was from a rival football firm whoa yeah
oh I heard about that yeah that's right
I heard about that and that's why they
canceled the fight yeah they moved it
over to Australia like they came around
security they came through the glass in
the arena just and if it wasn't for
Steve that that whole thing would have
gone south like he's the yeah dude you
imagine if there was a [ __ ] hooligan
brawl in the middle of the UFC I'll be
awful terrible for the sport yeah yeah
now Steve is uh is a wise man studies
everything how do you feel like Romero
and cast it plays out if you had a bank
on it if I gave you a hundred bucks well
hey what do you see I see this play out
I think coaster starts fast and I think
he pushes Romero back up against the
fence
Romero defends it do you know covers and
covers throws a couple of shots to push
cost her back and I think the second
round comes and Koster comes crashing
forward and Romero catches him with
something right hook over the top
something like that the technique I'm
watching out for for Kosta which he's
gonna be useful for Romero
he throws a great body kick to left hook
and Romero's got this bad habit and you
can see it all the way through the
Whitaker fights every time someone
throws a kick he does this like
overdramatized scoop with his arm to
like parry it out of the way if he's
parrying out the way that body kick
isn't you wide open for the left hook so
that's something I'm watching out for
with Kosta I just feel like he's
overconfidence he's willingness to take
risks and the fact that Romero's patient
can take his time he's never in a rush
to get the knockout because he knows he
can get it at any point in the fight I
feel like his patience might play off
and cost him I might walk on to
something hmm imagine if he chaos Kosta
and we play this over that happen is
it's gonna be completely opposite and it
would be like why is he got a job with
the UFC is no list well every now and
then you're so wrong like when Derrick
Lewis fought Francis in Ghana I was like
holy [ __ ] don't go for popcorn this is
gonna be [ __ ] chaos this is gonna be
[ __ ] chaos I was nervous before that
fight start I was like holy [ __ ] here we
go I'm like Francis and Cohn was gonna
be gunning for the title again he's
gonna come out guns blazing
Derrick Lewis goes to war every single
goddamn time they're both enormous like
[ __ ] here we go
nothing nothing nothing nothing but were
you working with crews on that night
somebody else who you were working with
and they said the words that you never
say during a heavyweight fight as soon
as it's about to start they go there's
no way this is going the distance
oh yeah that's a rough thing so he
straight away and I remember this like I
was so excited they went there's no way
this is going the distance unlike Oh
would you put that back
[Applause]